además de trasladarnos a casa la
pandemia ha hecho frecuente el meme del
capitán haddock y tintín que semana a
capitán es miércoles y ningún diálogo
resume mejor el mal trago que hoy vive
la asociación de prensa extranjera de
hollywood su semana de colapso inició el
6 de mayo cuando netflix renunció a todo
lazo con el grupo que entrega los globos
de oro al día siguiente a la medida se
sumó a amazon pero fue el día que la
agonía le llegó tras conocer que la
cadena en vis y compañera financiera
desde 1996 no emitirá por televisión sus
premios de 2022 seguimos creyendo que la
asociación está comprometida con una
reforma significativa sin embargo un
cambio de esta magnitud no requiere
tiempo y trabajo para hacerlo bien
suponiendo que la organización ejecuta
su plan tenemos la esperanza de estar en
condiciones de emitir la gala en 2023 si
respecto a la hf pea por sus siglas en
inglés han leído abismo extinción o
desapariciones porque depende de la
reforma total de su reglamento tachado
de corrupto y nada diverso las denuncias
no son nuevas
medios mayors y hasta una coalición de
publicistas llevan años cuestionando sus
apenas 86 miembros que por ver en 2022
filmes extranjeros nominados 24
recibieron tres mil 465 dólares a
relojes regalados y viajes dudosos se
añade también racismo no hay integrantes
racializados y acusaciones de acoso
sexual por todo el actor tom cruise
remató el boicot devolviendo sus tres
globos de oro mientras que ya se busca
el reemplazante que hará de antesala a
los oscars del próximo año
[Música]
morirá el grupo que nació en 1944 lo
desterrar a hollywood si si no cambia a
tiempo por más que se haya decidido
aumentar en un 50% a la membresía y
hacer públicos sus códigos de conducta
en lo inmediato no tratará a la gran
villana de mayo que por supuesto es
cruel ha disponible en salas y disney
plans son dos en más stone y thompson
quienes ponen precisamente piel al
origen de la malva la diseñadora 60 años
después de la animación 101 dálmatas y
mich entonces y en el 96 con glenn close
que ahora es productora nos fijamos en
su ambición por los abrigos de animales
hoy será un londres de los 70 el que nos
contará la construcción de su vileza a
ritmo de funk rock y a ello contribuye
florence and the machine cuya líder
aprendió a cantar de niña con disney así
como el compositor nicolás beat el que
está encargado de grabar la banda sonora
con cinta analógica en una escena la
baronesa hayman se cuestiona si éste la
tiene instinto asesino ya saben la
respuesta
así visionados
[Música]
es más los pasos y
qué tal
[Música]
sí no
[Aplausos]
y lo que sigue audiovisualmente es para
sacar agenda en gran pantalla pero de
streaming está ok si gente del galo
lexan hi a un thriller cuya trama se
cuenta rápido porque sólo tiene un
personaje el de melanie log on que está
encerrada en una cápsula criogénica en
la que un interlocutor robot le informa
que por una falla irá perdiendo el 35%
de oxígeno que ostentan lo virtuoso es
que este micro escenario muestra cuánto
se puede lograr en pandemia si se
recrean bien los recuerdos que responden
porque está allí si se tiene luego
haciéndonos sentir esa asfixia y si se
es allá logrando con poco gran narrativa
porque no detecte
y el ministerio es hans son recordar a
american crime story y su trama sobre
versace si bien aquí ewan mcgregor
cuenta el auge y caída del diseñador de
moda estadounidense roy halston quien
tras un imperio de sexo y estatus en el
nueva york de los 70-80 perderá el
control de sí mismo y hasta de su firma
mientras que si cuela se apoyaba en la
escritura de dodie smith vía underground
railroad tiene pluma del pulitzer colson
whitehead con dirección del oscarizado
barry jenkins su relato la desesperada
lucha y huida de cora que escapando de
la plantación de un cazarrecompensas y
del pasado materno hallará que el
ferrocarril subterráneo existe guiando
la a través de la libertad en alusión a
las rutas y casas que ayudaban a los
esclavos sureños
aunque hoy la industria ha acaparado no
podíamos sino despedirlos con bob marley
break
[Música]
han pasado 40 años de su muerte por un
cáncer que afirmó que inició en un dedo
del pie y pueden creer que durante
décadas hubo medios que siguieron
pidiéndole entrevistas entre ellos la
bbc- en 2005 claro que con su música
llena de energías y su estética
jamaiquina se encargó de coronarse rey
del reggae incluso póstumo su trabajo de
1984 el recopilatorio legend se
convirtió en el más vendido del género
pero basta con mirar el hoy ya que según
forbes en 2020 fue la octava celebridad
fallecida que más billetes ganó es
difícil elegir get up stand up es muy
del contexto actual pero les invito a
escribir su tema favorito cuídense
[Música]
y
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bien
espalda
[Música]
sonia cada sábado
con vistas a texto